tras meses de tensiones latentes el
ejército de mianmar ha llevado a cabo lo
que muchos temían un golpe de
estado-militar en un mensaje transmitido
a través de un canal de televisión que
pertenece a los militares se anunció que
el ejército tomaba el control del país
durante un año con el fin de llevar a
cabo el escrutinio de las listas de
votantes y tomar medidas
la autoridad de la legislación la
gobernanza y la jurisdicción de la
nación se transfiere al comandante en
jefe en conformidad con el artículo 418
sub artículo a cámara o cabeza sigue
luchando yo también perdí el partido
gobernante de mianmar aseguró que aún
son sus y fue arrestada en una redada
matutina junto con otras figuras
importantes del oficialismo un
movimiento significativo que se produce
el día que se suponía que el parlamento
se reuniría por primera vez desde las
elecciones de noviembre desde esa
votación las tensiones han aumentado
entre los líderes civiles del país y sus
poderosos militares los líderes del
ejército afirman que las elecciones que
aún son sus y ganó de forma aplastante
fueron fraudulentas los informes de los
medios dicen que se cortaron las líneas
telefónicas e interna
en la capital y la televisión estatal no
pudo transmitir también ha habido
informes de soldados en las calles de
las grandes ciudades las condenas en
todo el mundo por lo ocurrido no han
tardado washington amenazó con una
respuesta si los líderes civiles no son
liberados aún sanssouci ha dirigido
mianmar durante los últimos cinco años
en el pasado fue vista como un icono de
la paz en occidente pero su liderazgo se
ha visto empañado por el trato brutal a
la minoría musulmana rohingya del país
considerada por naciones unidas como un
pueblo sin estado